b
the fall of saigon was nearly 40 years
ago on april 30th 1975.
next on american history tv the
university of louisville hosts a panel
of south vietnamese refugees including
veterans of the south vietnamese army
and air force
they reflect on their vietnam war
experience and escape from the country
following the fall of saigon
the panelists eventually settled in
kentucky this is about an hour and a
half
so i would like to introduce now the two
moderators for tonight um dd tran and
dow tran
no relations by the way
they are really amazing folks and they
are really the leading effort and
community leading effort behind moving
voices and and behind this evening
tonight
um it is amazing to have worked with
them over the last few weeks in putting
together this event um dd is a daughter
of vietnam war refugees she's an
attorney
um she is also a u of l and mcconnell
center alum
um and and this is makes me really
really proud she will enter
the army army jag corps
actually this friday so this is this is
really her last big event in civilian
life before she's joining jack
and she will she will ship out to fort
benning on friday so so that that that
is it see her you know
goodbye to civilian life here for a
while
um
and then we have dao here um also a u of
l alum um and also with a masters from
the kent school of social work
and and
she came to louisville as a refugee as
well with her family in 1994.
so without further ado please welcome
our two moderators and i'm looking
forward to an exciting evening
[Applause]
thank you daniel and the university of
louisville for sponsoring tonight's
fantastic program
can you guys hear me okay
okay good
ladies and gentlemen my name is dede and
my colleague right here her name is tao
like professor krebs said we're not
related it's just a very common last
name we are both with moving voices and
moving voices we have um it's our
mission to bring more attention to the
south vietnamese perspective
we want people to know that south
vietnam fought bravely and risked
everything for freedom
unfortunately it's often a perspective
that is overlooked in our public
discussion about vietnam war so we are
so thrilled tonight to help the
university of louisville put together
unheard tales of the vietnam war a south
vietnamese perspective from kentucky
we have a great panel of speakers here
with us they serve in south vietnam also
known as the republic of vietnam
they have amazing stories of the vietnam
war and their journey to kentucky so i'm
going to go ahead and introduce our
speakers starting on the left is dr gary
tran
he was a cabinet member and vice
minister of agriculture for the republic
of vietnam under president wang van pau
during the vietnam war today he is a
veterinarian and operates a kumon math
and reading school in louisville
kentucky he is also the first vietnamese
american to be a kentucky colonel
next we have mr tim win to his left he
was an american trained gunship pilot in
the air force of the republic of vietnam
today he works for catholic charities
where he helps settle refugees in
louisville
[Applause]
mr hungley was also an american train
pilot in the air force of the republic
of vietnam today he is an entrepreneur
in louisville and is heavily involved in
the vietnam veterans activities and
community service
[Applause]
dr craig tran was a physician officer in
the army of the republic of vietnam
today he works as a doctor at fort knox
and finally we have mrs hal tran she was
a pharmacy student when she married dr
coy tran during the war today she and
her husband reside in elizabethtown
kentucky
[Applause]
and likely dede said before we have five
people up here with the last name tran
none of us are related
except for the married couple
i hope they're related
but not in that way
[Music]
all right so we want to begin tonight's
conversation um with the start of the
vietnam war uh
dr gary tran you were a veterinarian
student at the university of oklahoma
when the vietnam war broke out
how did you learn about the war overseas
and how did you feel about your country
going to war
thank you dede
but before i say anything i would like
to take this opportunity
to con
way to convey to our
brave
veterans
our
deep appreciation and profile
gratitude
for
your noble sacrifice during the war
[Applause]
i learned
from the war from
tv as a student at osu like a most
american at that time it was the first
tv war
as you remember
every day
at seven o'clock
uh
i was glued to the tv
for news
of the war
and
it i was very worried for my family
because we live at the countryside
where
the war was
happening
and
of course you know we
saw daily
death and destruction
and
the feeling was very
um
very
sad and very apprehensive
okay and i remember
i was trying to study so hard
to
finish the program as fast as fast as i
could so that i can go home
you mentioned that your family was from
the countryside you're a son of a farmer
and eventually
um dr tran you went back to vietnam to
serve as a high-ranking bureaucrat can
you tell us
about some of those government roles and
why they were important to the war
my father is a was a poultry farmer
and he raised chicken
so when i came to this country
i want i wanted to be trained in police
science
and
later veterinary veterinary medicine
we were the first
in what they call the leadership
training program
sponsored by usaid
at that time
every year
they sent a dozen
young vietnamese that just graduated
from
high school
to go
to study different field
in the united states
and
it was
it was called leadership training
there were
about a dozen of these programs
all through the war years because there
there were other
students sent here
to study
other field also but
our group
were very special because
from
these groups
a lot of
uh high official in the
government
were selected
okay i
was lucky in the in the way that
all the major
agricultural development program
of the republic of vietnam
at that time
were either
supervised or implemented
by me directly
and
later on
if a time permit i will mention
[Music]
assure these program for you
the
one program that was the most
important and the most striking
was the land to the dealer program
it was a land reform program
and
it was so
revolutionary
that
dr
taylor who was the
professor of vietnamese study at cornell
university
said that it was
the major
achievement
of the
republic of vietnam
now
to dwell into
the detail of that program i have to
wait until my
colleagues have
a chance to answer so that i can
have time to
to go over that program with you
so as the vietnam
war escalated south vietnam like the
united states um
sorry can you get me better now
so as the war escalated south vietnam
like the united states
built its military force through
voluntary enlistment and through the
draft and so this question is for dr
quay tran you were drafted into the army
as a military doctor so how did you and
your family feel when you were drafted
um
i think that
before we
get into the draft in
in in vietnam at that time we need to
understand the atmosphere in which
the vietnamese live at that time
every family have people in the army
nobody is spared that
by that i mean that
if you
are a teacher or professor at school you
have to
to be in the army
learn about military
some training and after that they
reassign you to work in the university
or to certain school
or you you go back and
become a doctor so
everybody
in the 60
in the 70s
any family always have
people some way somehow connected to the
army at that time
so
i i grew up in in that atmosphere and
then
i
i finished med school the reason i i was
able to finish med school because i have
a waiver
to go to school
if anybody who fell
during the year at the end of the year
the exam and then you are drafted
into the army right away i have friends
who who were dropped
you know in the middle of the certain
year
and then so
in
i finished med school in 1974
and early 75 you know i
after i
i you know i i recently married
my wife in the end of 74 i were drafted
in
january 75
so
um
that's the way we we we we we leave and
then
not
a little bit anxious but not very
surprised and then my family the same
because everybody in the family my my
father was a retired lutheran colonel at
that time and then
my my brother at that time was already
in the army so you know
there's really nothing
particular
yeah so it was very normal for that time
period yeah everybody
mr lee you had a different experience
you actually
volunteered to join the air force after
you graduated from high school so why
did you decide to volunteer
yeah
you know as
dr chen has said about that that's every
family every
young
people thank you
some would somehow have to get into the
military or
with any
connection
and for me you know in vietnam uh
if
according to the army you you have to be
trapped
but for the navy and air force it's not
dropped it's volunteer
yeah
so that means if you were dropped into
the army
and after you finish the military
training
you can apply for
the job in air force or
in the navy
so that's why for me
directly volunteer
to the air force that's that's my case
okay yeah
like most south dames pilots you were
sent to america to finish your training
just like as mr one to your right did
and so could you talk to um
about some of your military training in
america mr lee
okay um
when i was young
i think that about 11 or 12 years old in
middle school
in my in my neighborhood there's a lot
of
big brother
they are the member of the air force
they wear cover
fly suit
with a pistol on the side another size
knife
it looks very black flying
you know
look it look like the angel
yeah sunglasses ribbon yeah okay
cool so cool
uh it doesn't mean it's cool it's very
cool at that time so i dreamed to be
a pilot at that time
and
when i
went up to high school
i am presented to my father my father is
a 15 years old 15 years veteran of the
army
he advised me okay if you want to go to
college or you want to join the air
force it depends on you that's your
future
you have a total
decision about that
but you have to study hard you have to
exercise more so you can get the
physical fit
and your dream might become true
and finally
in 1972
they got the recruitment campaign at
that time
they they recruit a lot of
members for the air force
and i applied for that
and
after five days
of
physical examination
with a group of 150 people
only 23 people
get into
the air force
the rest will be going to the
army school yeah to be there the
army officer instead of air force
officer
and
i love that to be the
the pilot you have to be
sent over to america for training
that's a good thing so you can open your
mind
to to the world
and when we join the effort we have a
chance to learn more about the english
about the american english about the
culture of the america
and finally we passed several exams
and we sent to
laguardia air force base
under the
management of the air force
to that trend over there
and after four four months
and we passed several exams as well
and they sent us to flight school
and for me i learned helicopter in fort
rocker alabama
so um after you both did your training
so you missed one did you train in
america you came back to vietnam to
serve so mr winn you came back to serve
as a gunship pilot can you tell us about
your most memorable combat experience
uh good evening ladies and gentlemen
i was the first lieutenant
with the black dragon ignited in south
vietnam air force
we provided fire support
to all four military areas in south
vietnam
like i tell you a little bit about the
flame that i flew
i flew an actor caco
gunship
it was a gecko aircraft converted to
gunship
this aircraft
provided close fire support
for south vietnamese and friendly troops
with the ability
to
fire up to 6 000 droughts per minute
from each guns
and deliver
deadly accuracy
submission
for the black dragon
was
to attack
targets on ho chi minh trail
one night on
november 27 1931
it's a thanksgiving day
we found
a new vietnamese convoy of five ducks
it's a rare catch for the black region
we are burping up to by bumping up to
2000 feet
open up on the ducks with four or
miniguns
the ducks disappear
in the cloud of dust
as we shower them with thousands of
brows
in about 10 minutes
and another night that i cannot forget
was
when a gi on the route
about
about to be overrun by the victim troops
told with the air fighting contact
person
we didn't want an f5
give me get me a black crayon
that was happened
one night
in the summer of 1972
at the outbound in thailand city
right the border of cambodia and vietnam
the
the victim troops
attacked the camp freely
we were outnumbered
there was just about a hundred years
from the camp
we came in
grab the flare
to identify attack yes
i saw a hundreds of vickers
who tried to get in the camp
i thought to myself
don't hesitate
bush sticker
fight
on four guns at once
we heard i heard on the radio our friend
took voice
put it closer closer closer
the vehicle
had a pretty good anti-aircraft guns not
nine
they look like july 4
5 work
outside
we
i shower them
with thousands of brows
until i run out of ammunition
another black dragon came to replace us
when i when i get back to the base
we found out that
we had been hit
there were four horns
on the field like the blooded aircraft
and the next morning
i knew that the vehicle paid very high
price for the attack last night
and our boss was there
and often the message
we heard on the radio
was the same
thanks black dragon
we won't be here without you
and it makes us feel very good
when we have that
thank you
[Applause]
well as many here know
the vietnam war produced huge numbers of
casualties
over 58 000 american soldier lives were
lost
when we talk about south vietnam
over
actually around 250 000
of south vietnamese soldiers were lost
and so in this portion of the program um
we want to show you an interview that we
did with an individual in louisville his
name is mr slowly
he was a cia operative and member of the
south vietnamese special forces and in
this clip he's going to talk about
losing his friends so
clippy do you want to turn down the
lights or no lights okay
all right
foreign
away
foreign
now
uh
thought
foreign
foreign
foreign
m
foreign
foreign
um
for anyone on our panel you know what
are your thoughts after watching this
clip
actually through this to this clip
i want to
give my opinion that the war is always
bad
nobody won the war
but we have to face the war it will come
and right now the war they have
several faces
not by the
the gun
and the ammo
but by the economic means
or by intelligence or
i.t uh something like that
so be careful about that and uh
well to face about face the war any war
to preserve the peace like that
we prevent the war by
prepare for the war
and
right now
all of the people vietnamese people
overseas outside vietnam
they try to
to
to fight
with the communist government right now
to get
the freedom of speech
the freedom of religion
and
everything else for vietnamese people
we don't want to fight them
but we want to
to struggle with them
to
to find any means
so we can get the freedom for our people
in vietnam and
everybody in the world as well thank you
with the
with us
we will fight the bylaws
so happens so very often
uh you know
sometime in the morning we sit together
we had breakfast with a wee drink coffee
we jogging
but you know about noon i heard that he
got shot down
he got shot down and never came back
so you know you see your friend in the
morning
and noon or the afternoon you heard that
he got struck down
this is
terrible
so that is the world
the world no one wants the world yes
but we with us the south vietnamese we
have to do we have to do it we have to
stand to against the communists because
the invaders
we have to fight to gain the communist
aggression
but unfortunately you know we lost the
world
i would like to
share with you some of my
experience
when i work at four knows
i had the privilege
of taking care of many
american soldiers who come from
afghanistan
or
iraq
and
many many
suffer from ptsd
that's what i see the most
and
what
hurt me the most is
many of the
wife
when these people come back
they don't recognize them anymore
these people come back really a
different
person
and many
left them
that's what i find out when i
take care of these people
so this is
some of the loss that these soldiers
gone through even though they come back
alive
the world but these
will probably affect them for the whole
the whole life
just like
you see the man that you see in here
at this age he still be affected
by the world that he went through
the cost of the war was very high in
many different ways so the united states
military withdrew its support of south
vietnam in 1973
for dr gary tran how do you feel when
the america were true
for us it was a very
puzzling
situation
because all along we were
told that the united states would
support us and our life and death
struggle
uh against
uh
the
the the the evil empire
which is communism okay
um
but all of a sudden you know
we were left
without a lot of logistical support to
fight
during the
last year
of the war
and it was very disheartening
because
personally
i think that if we
would have
the uh
support that
president nixon from med promise uh
president hill
you know to support us
if the communists
violated the
paris accord
you know he would retaliate he would
retaliate
severely
but
that was not forthcoming
so
even though we have the will and the
manpower to carry on
but we could not because
of the
lack of logistical support
toward the end of the war
imagine that we could not even get 300
million dollars
through congress
to buy gasoline for our airplane and
ammunition
for our
soldiers
whereas our enemy got four billion
dollars eight
military aids from
china and from russia
from the soviet union
this is why one of the big reasons we
lost the war
you know eventually saigon the capital
of south vietnam fell on april 30th 1975
and that date marked the end of the
vietnam war it's a very important date
that's engraved in many of our minds
mrs howe tran on that date april 30th
1950 75 excuse me where were you and
what were you
doing
i lived in saigon since 1954
when the geneva treaty
decided to have our country
in two parts the north
belongs to the communists and the south
to the nationalists
and
my family
since
they have heard about
experience with the communism
and my parents at that time
they very young
36 and 32
with seven children aging from
11 years old
to four months old
we
left
our home
from the north and moved to the south to
be able to live in freedom
so
because
we already had the experience with the
communists
even struggling to
start a new life in the south
after a few years my parents would be
able to prosper and
all of us
went to college
i was in the second year of pharmacy
school when i met my husband
in mexico who was a medical student
through the catholic youth
so
we
dating but waiting until we graduate
from
college and get married in 1974
so as you know that my husband was
dropped after he finished school
so he
eventually became a
lieutenant
and the fall of saigon came
before
the four or five days we we heard from
his father that
there's
an
uncle who worked for cia and he offered
that
we can go by plane
to the u.s
but there's a lot of people on the list
so
we wouldn't be able to
to go
on on the first day it was friday
so we came back home and then on
on monday the
april the 28th
uh his uncle called and asked us to to
come back to
to waiting for the bus to go to
the airport so it was on tuesday the
29th we were in his office and waiting
for the bus
but
around noon we heard from we listened to
the radio that the south
vietnam government
surrendered
so we hurried back home to my parents
home
at that time
the whole big family my parents my
uncle my two aunts family and my
grandparents
we all
prepared to go to the
commercial
pier
to
wear the ship dog to find a way to
to get on the ship
flee the country
so because we have a big
family and we had just four cars
so we divide
it by two groups
the first group went to the pier first
and then planning to go back
home to pick up the the rest of us
but when
the first group came to the pier uh
they saw the
card
chaotic
atmosphere at the pier
because everyone wanted to to flee the
country
so at that time my my father
thought about the rest of us still at
home so he decided to go back home
on
the next that was on the 29th on the 20
on the 30th of
april um
the communist army inflate
invading to the
president palace
and the situation at a time still
uh not settled so we still
everyone still want to go to flee the
country because there's a rumor that the
seventh fleet
of the
america still in the
south china sea
but
there's some hesitation because
people saying that the countries might
my
cutters
before we're getting out there
so we
the second time decided to stay
and then
life goes on
and i came back to to work as a
pharmacist because i graduated in 1974
and
my husband um
he went to his
brother-in-law's office
to practice
for a month and then in
june 1975
the communist government
called all of those
soldiers to
be present
and have a
study for re-education for three days
and after three days they released them
um mrs howe
um
you bring up a really interesting point
about the re-education camp on our panel
we have two people who actually went to
the re-education camp and the
re-education camp was really a way for
the north vietnamese
to seek revenge upon those who served in
south who served for south vietnam
they would imprison them they would
torture them they would forcibly
indoctrinate them
we'd like to ask mr wynn
after the war you were placed in a
re-education camp for four and a half
years
um you know can you describe what life
was like in a re-education camp
yes
i was i was in prison for four and a
half years in the
education labor camp in north vietnam
while there
the
non-communist vietnamese
controlled prisoners
by using what they call the stone mark
technique
the prisoners were fed
only sweet potato lightly
and a bowl of rice with one tiny base of
meat once a month
the technique
was designed to keep everyone so hungry
they could
only concentrate
on the hunger not escape
the prisoners including myself
were forced through high level
from sun up to stand up every day
under the harsh conditions
first
i was i was in the garden team
we planted all kinds of vegetables
spinach sweet potato
cabbage
depends on the season
and then
they put me in the cookie in the curtain
in the cutting wood team there were
about 15 of us
we went to the forest early in the
morning
cut the trees
carried the wood make the cam
in the afternoon
we work from 6 in the morning
until 6 in the evening
then around 7
all of us were locked up in one room
there were about there were about 60
prisoners in one room
we slept on the concrete floor
there was no restroom in the room
this one big bucket at the back of the
room
it was
terrible
and i didn't know how i am still alive
my 120 pound weight
dropped to
70 pounds
before i was finally released
and during my time in the labor camp
i watched
many of my friends died beside me
we had to grab the dead in pepper
and bury them in unmarked reps
and i cannot forget that it's still a
nightmare to me
thank you
um
dr coy train you also had a similar
experience you
were also in re-education came for three
years but you managed to escape
how do you escape
i think that
before we
we talk about the escape i need to have
some
clarification about the term
rare education camp
for people who never live with the
communists
or for the young people who was born
half in the 80s
maybe we talked about
radication came like
you know people go to certain place and
then have some kind of
education or you know have dinner or
lunch and then has a break and then have
you know served for them but
actually
it is a
correctional
labor camp
in the full sense of the term
but we keep using the term education
camp because
that's the invention of the communist
you know
has nothing to do with your education
it the indoctrination
and you you come there to work
and you
you you work like
you know
he described and then in between you
have some indoctrination
so
when i
i was in the camp this was almost three
and a half years already
and most of my friends they already
released after two years
and
we
we need to
to understand the atmosphere in which
that
why i had to escape
because
i have seen people
escape and never heard from these people
again
and i have seen people who escaped and
when they caught them
they put them in the connect if you know
what i mean connect these are the
container that
some of these
the shipping company they they put
people and and
the communists these people in
disconnect
in the sun
and put them in there
so i i've seen on that and then so
in the
in the years 77 and 70s
a
there's a movement
outside
in saigon that they the communists they
let chinese people go
at that time the communists they want to
get on the money from the
the the chinese so they they said that
if you
give me money i let you go
so a lot of people
um
try to get some
paper saying that they are chinese that
kind of thing so
i i live in in
in the camera that time and then
my wife she came and she tell me that
you know people going i heard some of my
friends they already
succeeded in
escaping from vietnam by that round so
she came
and then she tell me whether i want to
to
to escape
you know so i because i was so hopeless
i don't see any
um
the way that i can get out so i i decide
to go but i i don't know how to to
escape because
it's in the middle of the jungle
and
i'm not really a soldier like a real
soldier doesn't know what direction to
go so i said that i had to get some help
so
i
i have a chance to talk to one of my
friends who they are really sonia you
know they know how to
which way to go and then
they they
he was able to get out at that time
and go in different direction that we
usually go to in the morning and then he
he he agreed to
escape with me
so
he he had a chance to talk to my wife
and then she
and you know she decided we we we
we
on the day that we decide to escape
you know both of us we we go so
you know
the day that because every day i have to
go out and work with with the other
people
as a doctor you know i carry some sofa
and then some
marijuana medication that's all we have
like like medication that's all we have
and some bandits that's on and then we
we go out and as soon as we go out
you know
we don't join the group we disappear
into the jungle and then i just follow
the other
you know my friend and then we walk in
the jungle for i don't know for an hour
two and then we come to a place that we
don't see my my wife yet and then she
she came and then she she came and then
we keep walking and then i think in
about an hour or so and then finally we
see her with with a motorbike you know
the honda ammo to buy along with his
brother
so then we escape
can i add in a little detail
i i had a permit to visit him every
three months
to
provide
supply of food and money because
they don't have
enough money to
to give them
food
so
the last time it was on
in january
1979 and he already there for two and a
half half years so i
came to the cam on wednesday
and then we
can stay together during the night on
wednesday night and then i told him that
the plan
and then i will come back on monday
four days after
so
the next day when he
had to go back to uh
to the camp with other people to go to
to do labor
and then he told his friend to meet me
at the
on the way he wrote to the labor and
then i i talked with his friend about
the plan so that's why
he rely on the friend
and because he's a professional soldier
so
he already went out to that area to to
do labor work a couple months before so
he knew the way
and then on monday we came back
i had to ask my
cousin to ride a motorcycle and then
the friend's
brother he wrote another one
so after we
come to the place that we didn't meet
him and his friend and then we go
further a little bit and then we saw two
men
with the
civilian clothes because they had to
wear
military gloves in the camp
the two men carried the bag like the
patient
on the road and then
we picked them up and then just rode
back in saigon without any problem
they they don't have any intelligent uh
gods
on the road very good plane
they are very courageous
situation so
i
i don't have any other thing that
i can do for my husband so
that's what i don't know whether the
holy spirit guide me to do it or not
so as the conditions worsen an estimated
two million vietnamese people attempted
to escape the country
most famous for the bull people and so
dr cray and his wife
eventually
escaped by boat and came to america
mr lee he actually also tried to escape
vietnam 10 times unsuccessfully
and then continue to live in vietnam for
the next 30 years so can you describe
what life was like under communist
vietnam
um
i'm
the unlucky people
i'm trying many times but fail
but i still have a lot of friends
still in vietnam right now because they
they don't have any chance to get out
finally i
i've been here 13 years
finally i find my luck
i'm not in the camp because there are
some serious situation of myself so but
my friends
just like dr
town here and
mr win here in the camp
they tried to escape
some some of them were escaped several
times but fell
and then when they got back to the camp
they tried to kill them and actually
several people have died because of that
is that right yeah yeah
so in in in the situation of dr tran
here is very lucky
yeah and it looks like
playing the game right not not a scam
and for me
i'm living
under the communists about 28 years
before coming here
and you know the first 10 years is very
terrible
the whole country i mean the south
vietnam
i don't talk about in north vietnam
because i don't know anything about that
but they're not vietnam i don't think
that
they better than the salvation people
they don't have enough
food for eating even not in the north
and in the south at that time we don't
have enough food we don't have enough
medicine
and
we left everything
in the first 10 years
and you know that
the fuel
the kerosene for
for burning the light at night
and for cooking as well
we lack the best as well
because at that time nobody want to
to play with the communists
and the people in in the south will not
only try to get out
and the western country outside they
don't want to play with them the
communists
so finally the first year the second
year and then the third year we don't
have anything left
so that that's why i i put that about 10
years the first 10 years is very very
terrible for
the whole south vietnam people
and after 10 years is a little bit
better
after 10 years after 10 years in
1975 that means 20 years later
the vietnam and the united states they
got the diplomatic
diplomatic relationship again
so from 95
is
it got more improvement
yeah
well we're glad that you're able to
finally make it here to america um
like most of our speakers here most and
ended up in kentucky through a federal
resettlement
program today more than 5 800 vietnamese
americans live in kentucky and that's a
low number we expect a lot more they're
currently living here
so
we thank the speakers again for sharing
their stories with us
our time is limited but so right now
what we would like to do is to open up
our panel for questions from the
audience
um
just a reminder again
you do have to speak into the microphone
there's only one in the room so please
wait for the microphone to come to you
before you ask your question
so the lady in the front
thank you
the three gentlemen to my left were you
able to bring your families
is
so the question was for the three
gentlemen on the left were you able to
bring your families over
yes yes
thank you for your
wonderful description
is this on
okay thank you very much for your
service and your
the mic is actually for
c-span so it's just picking up for their
their mics so we'll just repeat your
question
okay
um there's been a great deal of
discussion about agent orange there are
two sides
it's something that was used in war and
as was said war is always terrible
others
feel it saved american lives i'm curious
as
americans who came from the south of
vietnam
what are your feelings about this and i
would tell you i've been working for 30
years in vietnam on this topic but i'm
curious to know your perceptions and
your thoughts about ancient orange
can you repeat that just let just a
question
it's about agent orange
now the gentleman's been working on
studying and he believes some it saved
people's lives but also i was just
asking your opinion on agent orange
okay so the question was about agent
orange and do any of the panelists have
any experience or opinions about agent
orange
and your perceptions as well
so we'll take we'll take one question at
a time we'll do the agent orange
question
anybody on the panel go ahead well i
feel i feel deeply and speaking to the
mic i feel i feel in that day
i feel deeply indebted to the american
sawyer
who
fought and died for our countries
and and i saw i saw the courage when i
you know when we when we when we fly
along them
you know because there is the fries
that's right pilot he might swear
and he flew with us
he blocked every combat missions
i very appreciate that and you know i
feel that i own my own you know
i own the american soldiers
you know because you know they're far
away they came and and they came and
fight for us and they die for us
i very grateful
yes we grateful about the
american
soldier
and officer to come to our country to
fight against communism
but the
communists
they they use the term of fighting
against
the imperialism of
america
but actually it was a civil war
between the two different idealism
it's not fighting american but they use
that term to draw young people to go
with them and fighting against the
south vietnam
did any of our panelists have a response
to the gentleman's question to back in
the back about agent orange
if if not we'll move on to the next
question
i
i don't have much knowledge about the
asian orange
the only thing i know is that in vietnam
they they have some kind of center
because they want to get the money
compensation for the united states so
they
everything that they say
that this from agent orange but i i
don't know more about that the only
thing i know is that they want to get
the money from the americans so they all
the people who have some kind of
information they say that it's from
asian orange you know
that's all i i can think of
i want to add a little bit more about
the
asian orange
according to my knowledge
the american soldier
came to vietnam and back here
and now they they diagnosed with
some kind of dizzy because of asian
orange
and they got a conversation
they got treatment
they got all kind of stuff i
i think so
but you know in vietnam
the people there from the north from the
south or the civilian in the world
they still affected by
the asian orange as well
but they don't have anything
they don't have any compensation they
don't have any treatment
that's what what i i want to bring up
thank you
you know the
asian orange
was used in remote area where there's no
people living there except the
communists
you know in jungles
in
places where they can hide to ambush
our forces we have to use
these
a chemical to defoliate so that we can
see who's hiding where
so that we don't die from their ambush
so
i don't think
the americans use
that chemical
in places where there are people
uh living
you know usually
way in the boonies somewhere where
hardly anybody lives except the company
now if
the communists
are poisoned by that
so be it you know
because
they come to kill us they woke up on
yourself yeah they were enemies
next question
uh we had the ambassador to singapore uh
ambassador the us trump singapore here
about
six months ago spoke to the world
affairs council and he made an argument
i never heard before we always talked
about domino theory or what might happen
after the u.s left vietnam
what he said was that during the mid 60s
when singapore had just become
independent he was trying to decide
which way to go communist or capitalist
in it
he said mainly based on the u.s
participation in vietnam that they went
the capitalist model
i'd never heard that before i didn't
know if you'd heard that or what your
comments might be on that which reaction
might be
so the question was um the ambassador of
singapore was here and he had talked
about
the
independence of singapore and whether or
not they were going to choose to be a
communist country or a free country and
they looked to what had happened in
vietnam and decided to go with the
capitalist model well they look they
look to the u.s participation in vietnam
which what he said was very influential
they decided to go the more capitalistic
model
so
i'll just repeat what he said they
looked at the u.s
involvement in vietnam and they decided
to go with the capitalist route
have any of the panelists
heard of this before
or have any thoughts on that i was i was
too young you know
i was 24 35 years old so really i don't
know much about you know about politics
but i i think uh
hundred a million people
uh
left their home in the north to the
south that speak out about
whether we like communism or not
and i think most of the people in south
vietnam and even
some of the
vietnamese who stay behind in the north
they don't like communists at all
we have no freedom they kill people and
they use the
term of
killing people who own the who have
possession and they they kind of
praising the poor
but after
we stay behind after 1975
everyone became poor
no one
have anything and there's no freedom to
do anything
they destroyed even
the the symmetry
not in the central area but
in the suburbs as well so everyone had
to
cremate the
family
members who disease
and they used the symmetry in the center
to become a garden
so
you you can uh believe what the
community is saying
yes just watch them yes i agree with
that what our our last president
president will until he said that
then listen to what the companies said
look at what they have done
and if you look at if we look at the
fact
that you know north and south nor south
vietnam we are the south
we did not invade the north the law
came and invade us
we just want the sovereign people just
want to live in peace
with the south but with the south
vietnamese people that's what to lean
base there are no other communists
vietnamese
they they they did not like we do that
and we just we have to stand up to
defend ourselves ourselves
but
unfortunately you know because i think
the battlefield is not in vietnam the
battlefield in here united states
we lost the world because they cut off
everything to us
like i was a pilot but i have i have to
round every i have i was i was being
crowded for years
because no gas no fuel
no ammunition
so of course we lost the world
at the battlefield i think in here
united states
not in vietnam
the front line the front line the
battlefield the front of the battlefield
in here united states nothing vietnam
we lost the world because the people
united states we go to congress
we go to congress
stop you know
your support out the support to us while
the north vietnamese still got a support
from russia and china
nobody in his or her right mind would
want to live under communism
once the people know what companies
they usually
flee
that's why
more than half of a million butch people
die
trying to escape from communism
if they let
people go freely the whole country would
leave vietnam right now except
the the the few thousand
a few hundred thousand
communist cadres
that regime have to use
uh police
to force people
to live there
um we'll take a question in the back i
think i saw a hand in the back behind
you
sir was there a question back there
no
yes there was a vietnamese orphanage run
by
vietnamese nuns
south of tam key or near tam key what
happened to the vietnamese religious
people
the ministers the
priests the nuns and all them what
happened to the vietnamese religious
people
as i understood in it because i live in
saigon so i would be able to to go to
to the church and have activity in the
choir but people who live in
in the countryside
they have to wake up very early in the
morning to to go to church on sunday
because they forced them to work on
sunday
and later on i
i heard about
many places they tried to to take on the
properties of the church even the
symmetry
so
they still have
a lot of struggle between
the government and the religious
people
and some of the
priests are bishop
if they speak out
and they they have to put into prison
next question please
thank you
there's a film making the rounds on pbs
called uh last days in vietnam by rory
kennedy that probably some of you have
seen my wife and i saw it and made a
great impression on us curious to know
if any of you have seen and what your
general impressions of the film are more
specifically
there's an assertion in the film that
north vietnam intended to honor the
paris peace accord primarily because
they were afraid of richard nixon they
thought he was crazy
and when the watergate scandal broke and
he was weakened politically that's what
encouraged them to invade the south
curious to know your opinion on that as
well
so the question is um this gentleman saw
the film last days in vietnam and wanted
to know if anyone on the panel had seen
it and what their impressions were also
um
he said that in the film there was an
assertion that the north vietnamese
invaded after they had saw that
the nixon watergate scandal
what are your thoughts on that
i agree with that assertion
because if
there were there were no water get
watergate
probably
president nixon would respond would
retaliate to the
fragrant violation of the paris accord
but i have another
thought about
nixon
when we see
president nixon
have agreement with china
and at that time
probably vietnam is not the front line
for the freedom country anymore
so
the people in america
because of the loss of 58 000
american soldiers
and
losing money
so they they don't want to to lose more
people and money anymore so i think
that's the which is a pawn on the
chessboard we have nothing to
to fight beside the aid from the america
like right now
if the american withdrawal from
afghanistan
i i think it will be terrible so when
president
rani came over
here last week to to call
to have
14 000 american
soldiers stay behind in afghanistan to
ensure the freedom of afghanistan
all right next question
dr gary tran you said that
everyone in vietnam would leave except
for a select few people if given the
opportunity to right now
i know that in recent years over the
last couple of decades we've opened up
relations with vietnam do you all agree
with this policy of the united states
the gentleman said that
dr gary tran had said that if
people could leave vietnam they would
except for a select few
recently the united states has opened up
with vietnam
what are your thoughts dr gary tran on
that
with the presence of
the american
embassy in vietnam
and with
a lot of
foreign contacted
came to vietnam to invest
um
i think
the the the the life
over there
get better because
the communists tend to um
you know pay attention to world opinion
for their
uh
international
aids and such that's why
um
you know with uh um
with the western
presence
thing uh tend to be better you just
compare vietnam with north korea which
is uh you know
very uh contrasting difference
in in north korea there's hardly any
western presence
uh that country is pure and adult under
adulterated hell okay
vietnam at least
people don't have freedom they don't
have human rights they don't have
a lot of
things that
we enjoy here but still
life is a little bit better than uh in
other places
so so the i think um
open up relation like this
is uh helpful at least for the people
alive over there
i think i think the worst the worst
thing in vietnam now if you
you can see it corruption and blinds
everywhere in vietnam
so the worst thing
in vietnam now
and
and you can see the difference between
the rich and the poor in vietnam in the
big gap
is that the minority you know is the
minority the communists the communist
party the company is the member comes
back they they get rich because they get
corrupt and they're priced
but a lot of people vietnamese people
you know
very poor
very very poor
all right next question
this is a question for dr gary tran um
you were agricultural
commissioner whatever the title properly
is
my understanding was
there is that vietnam
was
a largely rural
fundamentally agricultural comp country
before all the trouble so to speak
and uh was a net exporting company a
country uh for rice a very rich
agricultural
economy um
and you talked about
some of the programs that you were
starting there i'd like to hear more
about that and what the consequences of
the war were for agriculture and the the
nation's self-sufficiency
in terms of food
before you answer i just repeat the
question um dr gary tran you were the
agricultural specialist in the country
before the war vietnam was largely
largely rural and agricultural
and a net exporting
rice country
what consequences did the war have on
the economy
agricultural economy
land reform and agricultural development
are the two
major achievements
of the republic of vietnam but nobody
talked about it
in 2012
cornell university invited
about a dozen
of us high officials in the government
you know
i remember there were four
cabinet members
and
two uh one general and one admiral
and
a few politicians and
parliamentarians
go there for a symposium
and
there is a book that comes out that and
i wish you all read about this because
these are the things that nobody
talk about in the 3000
books and novel
published uh on vietnam and the vietnam
war okay i want to read because the the
achievement in agriculture is so massive
that it it would take me at least a day
to talk about it
because when i gave the talk at cornell
university
you know that they give two three days
for the whole bunch but
my fear took a whole day
because of that okay so please if you're
interested in that
uh get this book i will i will leave one
book for dr krabs in case you know you
can
use it let me
quote one
one
a couple of sentence from
the introduction of the book
from dr
keith taylor he's the only
vietnamese study professor in the united
states this is when he said to introduce
the book
the pace to war stereotype
among americans at that time and later
even to this day
of the second republic
as
the second republic government as a
dictatorship that deserves to be
defeated is perhaps a convenient slander
but it is a slander nevertheless
the efforts of vietnamese to create a
democratic government under adversity
is a story that has yet to break through
itself
uh to break through the uh
self-serving american myths that have
shrouded
what is probably the most revived
abandoned ally in u.s history the aim in
compiling this volume
is not only to retrieve the enemy voices
from the second republic
before they are gone
but also to give americans the option of
finally after half a century
seeing more clearly the ally for whom
thousands of americans
give their life
so
the the section on agricultural
development and reform is 50 page long
out of this 150 page book
so to tell you how massive
the achievement
in that field is you got to read this
book
thank you very much
i'm going to take the um privilege of
asking the last question because i know
all of you live here in louisville
and so if you could say here in one or
two sentences please we're running out
of time
um
how you came to louisville um as you
know leaving vietnam as refugees and
escaping camps or or otherwise making
your way out of vietnam and then
afterwards i would like to invite all of
you to ask further questions then
outside at the reception um where where
there's chance for conversation
and and also for the chance at the
exhibit to learn more about the conflict
and and and those those memories but
first um yeah how did you come to
louisville
go make
any
i was lucky because when i came here
when i came to the united states
one of my classmates dr sam here and
fern creek
offered me a job
so i came here to work for him for 10
years and then after that i split off
and then
practice
veterinary medicine on my own
and then 25 years ago i started
to train
louisvillian kids to be real good in
math and in english
dd
you see how good this is
she is one of my 3 000
smart
kids that we trained throughout school
that's why i became a kentucky colonel
not because i did anything in vietnam
actually i did a lot in vietnam if you
read this book you will see it
but because
i trained 3 000
children in louisville to be super good
in math and reading and they
later had the
awesome college
education
[Applause]
you're watching american history tv all
weekend every weekend on c-span 3.
to join the conversation like us on
facebook at cspan